نحن لا نقول إن حياتنا السوداء تهمك
أكثر مما نقول إن حياتنا السوداء
مهمة لوصول أكثر من
400 جامايكي سعيد قد أتوا لمساعدة
الوطن الأم على طول الطريق نحو
الازدهار بعيدًا عن آثار
الإمبراطورية و  بقايا عظمة استعمارية مهجورة منذ فترة طويلة ،
ما الذي يعنيه حقًا
أن تكون أسودًا وبريطانيًا اليوم ،
هذا هو بيرس الشاعر ، فنان كلمة منطوقة
يكافح لفهم
كل شيء من خلال قصائد مثل هذه وإذا
لم نسمع مع آني أو مع
رفع القبضة ، كيف يمكننا أن نقاوم ،
أعتقد أن أعظم خدعة عنصرية
تم لعبها على الإطلاق كانت إقناع إنجلترا بأنها غير
موجودة لعقود من الزمن ، كانت بريطانيا
لديها حسابها العرقي في
الماضي ، كانت الشرارة هي وحشية الشرطة ،
والظلم الاجتماعي أو عدم المساواة في الدخل ،
لكنها كانت تدعمها  كل الإحساس يقول الكثيرون
أن كونك أسودًا وأن تكون بريطانيًا يعني أن
تشعر أنك غير مرحب به في منزلك ، فإن
حركة حياة السود قد عبرت
المحيط الأطلسي وأيقظت محادثات غير مريحة
الأمة مقسمة
على أسس عرقية ،
لكن أن تكون شخصًا أسود يعني أن نعيش
في بلد مختلف ،
اكتسب خمسة أصدقاء بريطانيين سود شهرة عالمية
بعد صورة لهم وهم يحملون رجلاً أبيض
إلى بر الأمان وسط
اندلاع احتجاج عنيف في لندن.  تم
الترحيب بالفيروسات كأبطال ، لكن الحقيقة أكثر
تعقيدًا نحن كأخوة كأغاني لأن
الآباء لديهم القليل من الثقة في
الشرطة
يوم السبت ، حيث اضطررنا
للخروج للقيام بعملهم نيابةً عنهم ،
وجد استطلاعنا أن الأشخاص السود أكثر احتمالًا بمرتين من
البيض.  الأشخاص الذين يقولون إنهم
لم يعاملوا باحترام من قبل الشرطة كانوا
محميًا من قبل الشرطة ، فالشرطة
عنصرية مؤسسيًا ، فقد يكون هناك
أفراد داخل النظام
يحاولون القيام بعمل جيد ولكن كمجموعة ،
فهم عنصريون ، ما
رأيك في  يفكر ضابط الشرطة عندما
ينظر إليك ، لون العرق ، أول
شيء يلاحظونه ، يجب أن يكون آخر
شيء يلاحظونه
للأسف ، وهو التهديد الذي تعتقد أنه أول
شيء يراه ضابط الشرطة عندما  إنهم
ينظرون إليك كرجل أسود يمثل تهديدًا
وأعتقد أنهم يروننا لأن غالبية
المجتمع يعتبرنا تهديدًا وهو
الخوف وليس الشرطة فقط عندما
يتعلق الأمر بمؤسسات السلطة الأخرى ، فإن
الانقسام العرقي أسود صارخ تمامًا.
من المرجح بشكل كبير
أن يقول الناس عن الحزب
والسلطة إن المحافظين
عنصريون مؤسسيًا في اللحظات الأخيرة
من إسقاط تمثال
تاجر العبيد
إدوارد زي لأكثر من قرن كان
يترأس ميدانًا مركزيًا في
مدينة بريستول البريطانية  ثم استولت العمليات على
الأمور بأيديهم ، يمكنك
أن ترى اللحظات العاطفية الهائلة
عندما قام الحشد
الأبيض والأسود بتدوير تمثال كولستون
إلى الأرصفة حيث
تم بيع البشر الذين كان يتاجر بهم في المزاد العلني تمنى لو
كان هناك موسيقي محلي هناك في ذلك اليوم نشأ
في الظل  تمثال كولستون
وشاهده
[ضحك]
حسنًا هيكليًا آخر لهتلر ، فلماذا
ترفع تمثالًا له
كما تعلم أعني يقوده رئيس الوزراء
بوريس جونسون الذي  في وظيفته السابقة
كصحفي استخدمت افتراءات عنصرية من الحقبة الاستعمارية
للإشارة إلى الأفارقة ،
تهدد الحكومة البريطانية الآن
بسجن ما يصل إلى عشر سنوات
لما تسميه تدنيسًا للتاريخ ،
لكن تاريخهم وجد استطلاعنا أن
السود كانوا أكثر من  ضعف احتمال
دعم إزالة تلك التماثيل من خلال
العمليات مثل الأشخاص البيض وتقريباً
ثلاثة أضعاف احتمال القول بأن
الإمبراطورية البريطانية ككل كانت شيئًا سيئًا في
حقبة الحرب العالمية الثانية.
من
خلال إرث دوره في
الإمبراطورية البريطانية تحت تمثاله الخاضع لحراسة مشددة الآن ،
تحدثنا إلى مور لأنه
ليس فقط ماضي بريطانيا ، هذا الصراع
يتعلق أيضًا بحاضرها ، لقد فكرت لماذا
لا تستطيع امرأة سوداء أن تستخدم
صوتها وتنشر الكلمة  لأنه حتى هذه
الاحتجاجات لم أكن أعلم مطلقًا أن لدي صوتًا
، إيما البالغة من العمر ثمانية عشر عامًا ،
هي واحدة من
منظمي الاحتجاج البريطانيين "حياة السود".
كما واجهت مضايقات مستمرة
لهذا الدور وطلبت منا عدم استخدام
اسم عائلتها الأصلي من نيجيريا
وانتقلت إلى بريطانيا ، قالت إنه كان
صعبًا عندما انتقلت لأول مرة إلى هذا
البلد ، تلقيت رسائل عنصرية مجهولة
من أشخاص من جميع أنحاء منطقتي
وأعتقد أن هذا كان  الإدراك الأول
أن العنصرية بارزة جدًا في هذا
البلد والعنصرية الخفية الجهلة الذين يدخلون
الأنبوب ويرون النساء والرجال يمسكون
حقائبهم وحقائبهم ، حياتنا مهمة
ولن نتوقف حتى
تبذل الحكومة جهدًا للترويج لذلك
وهي  ليسوا وحدهم الذين يشعرون بهذه الطريقة
، من المرجح
أن يقول السود إن المملكة المتحدة لم
تفعل ما يكفي لمعالجة الظلم العنصري التاريخي ،
فما الذي تعنيه النتائج التي توصلنا
إليها لهذه الأمة المقسمة ما هو واضح
هو أن هناك انقسامًا بين ما  عانى العديد من
البريطانيين السود وما يعتقد العديد من
البريطانيين البيض أن هذه التجربة
تعني أن الكثير من
القادة السود هم من النشطاء السود  حتى
البريطانيين السود العاديين الذين ظلوا
يقولون منذ سنوات ، من الصحيح أنهم عندما
يتحدثون عن العنصرية فإن الكثير من
مواطنيهم البيض لا يصدقونهم
وهذا شيء يجب
أن يُحسب له حساب إذا كان هناك أي أمل
في ذلك  البلد للتحرك معا
نحو مستقبل موحد